they're fast rare and boast huge
spoilers the ford sierra RS cosworth and
the Ford Escort RS Cosworth to ordinary
family cars that were transformed into
lean mean driving machines and gave
purebred race cars a run for their money
the escort cosworth on the rally circuit
and the Sierra Cosworth on the racetrack
in the 1980s and 90s they both throw
their competitors into the ground using
almost identical technology
Christian Carville is lucky enough to
own both of these rare Crosse's he and
his colleague over shriner keep them in
tip-top condition Gothel says he's very
attached to the COS Worth's you might
say he even grew up in them his father
used them in lots of mountain rallies
and glottal has also tinkered around a
lot on the cars so he's very passionate
about the office the Sierra was the
first Ford to boast the Cosworth name
and the high performance version made
its debut in 1986 Ford wanted to clean
up on the racetrack but to do that the
car maker had to develop a version that
was street-legal to to fulfill the
requirements of group a racing the
series production model costs he boasted
a 204 horsepower 16-valve engine with an
intercooled turbo charger the
thoughtfully state-level says the most
striking thing about the Sierra Cosworth
is its huge rear spoiler which serves to
increase downforce at 200 kilometers an
hour the car exerts a downward thrust of
800 kilos which he says greatly
increases the vehicle stability extreme
face of it when it comes to the interior
cottle points out the Sierra Cosworth
recaro bucket seats it's 5-speed manual
gearbox and three-spoke steering wheel
he notes that the car has lots of dials
like the turbo indicator and the oil
pressure gauge which is vital for
monitoring fluid levels antonio the
tahoe psychic attack on water goes up to
260 kilometers an hour for kontol says
the ford can exceed that which is why it
was often dubbed a Porsche killer vital
notes that a Popoff valve has been
installed on his Sierra Cosworth and
that
strut bar isn't original either and that
here all the stainless steel pipes have
been handmade and reweld it he says the
car can reach 300 kilometres an hour and
his great fun to fly down the autobahn
in the Bunsen but first Gothel is taking
his souped-up 500 horsepower racer for a
spin on some country roads the whistling
sound the car makes while changing gears
is typical of the turbocharged costs
worth he says it's the sound of the Papa
valve which releases excess turbo boost
pressure when you take your foot off the
gas he says it sounds cool and protects
the engine and hoses because if this
pressure were reintroduced into the
system the hoses wouldn't last as long
valve and he said ok is a blessing it
reading in class last week distributed
and
I'm just like a nice tool I can even
start Christiane's second costs worth is
an escort hits the carport brought out
in 1993 with the aim of winning the
World Rally championships combining the
body of the standard escort with the
chassis and engine from the bigger
Sierra produced a small yet powerful and
agile car that was perfect for Mountain
rallies unlike Christians tuned Sierra
the escort cosworth is an original
series production version it can go from
zero to 100 kilometers an hour in 6.1
seconds and reach a top speed of 225
kilometers an hour christian says the
escort is most fun to drive on mountain
roads like this would tight curves and
quick stretches because it's so neutral
sporting an agile and curves this is the
place to drive it
lelu designer Christian says the escort
cosworth is suitable for everyday
driving but he adds that the car's not
the youngest and feels it would be a
shame just to use it for getting around
but for anyone looking for a sporty and
reliable modern classic that's fun to
drive the increasingly rare kasi is a
good choice